GEORGIA'S DEMOCRATIC
GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY IN
GEORGIA'S HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME, SO,
OBVIOUSLY, WE'VE ALL SEEN THE
PICTURE.
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE COVERAGE OF
THE PICTURE.
DID YOU MAKE A MISTAKE BY TAKING
A PHOTO MASKLESS IN THE
CLASSROOM WHEN IT APPEARS THAT
EVERYONE ELSE INCLUDING ALL THE
CHILDREN WERE WEARING THEM?
>> YES.
I WILL SAY THIS I WHEN TO THE
READ TO KIDS FOR AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN READ-IN DAY.
I APPROACHED THE PODIUM WITH MY
MASK ON.
I FOLLOWED THE PROTOCOL.
I TOLD THE KID I'M TAKING MY
MASK OFF BECAUSE I'M LISTENING
TO KIDS LISTENING REMOTELY AS
WELL, THE KIDS WERE SOCIALLY
DISTANCE FROM ME.
I TOLD THEM THAT'S WHAT I WAS
DOING.
THE EXCITEMENT BECAUSE IT WAS SO
MUCH FUN WORKING WITH THOSE
KIDS, I TOOK A PICK.
THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
PROTOCOLS MATTER IN PROTECTING
OUR KIDS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING AND ANYTHING PERCEIVED AS
UNDERMINING THAT IS A MISTAKE
AND I APOLOGIZE.
>> LET ME ASK YOU, AT THE HEART
OF THIS I UNDERSTAND, YOU ARE
APOLOGIZING FOR MAKING A
MISTAKE.
AT THE HEART OF THIS IS WHY WE
ARE IN THIS SITUATION TO BEGIN
W. RIGHT.
SOME PEOPLE STILL BELIEVE IN
MASK MANDATES, OTHERS FEEL IT IS
LONG PAST THE TIME.
ESPECIALLY WHEN ADULTS ARE NO
LONGER WEARING MASK MANDATES AND
MANDATES HAVE BEEN LIFTED.
YESTERDAY FOUR DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS SET SPECIFIC TIME
LINES TO LIFT MASK MANTATES IN
SCHOOLS IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
A NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR WIRES
CROSSED SAYING HE HAS RECEIVED
QUOTE OVERWHELMINGLY POSITIVE
REACTION TO HIS DECISION.
SO, DO YOU THINK IT'S TIME TO
LIFT THESE MASK REQUIREMENTS IN
SCHOOLS?
WOULD YOU LIFT THEM IN GEORGIA?
>> COVID PROTOCOLS WILL BE THERE
FOR A WHILE.
UNFORTUNATELY IN.
DPA, WE'RE NOT IN A PLACE WHERE
THAT CONVERSATION IS READY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE ONE OF THE
LOWEST VACCINATION RATES IN THE
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE 40% OF OUR COUNTY'S
WITHOUT GENERAL PEDIATRICIANS.
WE REFUSE TO EXPAND MEDICAID SO,
SO MANY FAMILIES DON'T HAVING A
SAYS TO HEALTHCARE.
I BELIEVE OUR JOB IS TO EDUCATE
CHILDREN.
I KNOW PARENTS HAVE TO BALANCE
EDUCATION AND THAT IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE.
I THINK EACH GOVERNOR HAS TO
EVALUATE WHAT'S HAPPENING WHERE
THEY ARE.
WE HAVE TO LOOK TO THE CDC AND
RECOGNIZE WE ARE SHIFTING FROM
PANDEMIC TO ENDEMIC.
SOME STATES WILL GET THERE
FASTER THAN OUGHTS.
MY RESPONSIBILITY IF I AM LUCKY
ENOUGH TO BE THE NEXT GOVERNOR
OF GEORGIA IS TO LOOK AT THE
SCIENCE TO FOLLOW THE PROTOCOLS
AND TO SET THE RIGHT EXAMPLE.
RIGHT NOW THAT EXAMPLE IS THAT
WE WEAR MASKS WHENEVER POSSIBLE.
BUT WE RECOGNIZE WE XANT BE A
HARD LINE ABOUT THIS.
BECAUSE SITUATION CHANGE AND WE
HAVE DIFFERENT MOMENTS WHERE WE
HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS, THAT IN
THIS INSTANCE, I WOULD SAY AS
THE GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA, MY JOB
WILL BE AT THAT TIME TO LOOK AT
THE SCIENCE TO LOOK AT THE
SITUATION, AND TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISION TO PROTECT OUR KIDS.
>> ALL I UNDERSTAND.
AT THE HEART OF IT, I'M A
PARENT.
MY KIDS WEAR MASKS IN SCHOOL.
THEY SAY THEY DON'T MIND.
BUT YOU KNOW ONE THING YOU SAID
STOOD OUT TO ME.
THAT IS BECAUSE YOU WERE
READING.
YOU WANTED THEM TO SEE YOU READ,
YOUR EXPRESSION.
THAT IS A PART OF THE REASON
PEOPLE FEEL THE THE WAY YOU
FEEL.
YOUR NATURAL INSTINCT.
I WANTED TO BE SHARE THAT.
DOES IT CONCERN YOU THESE MASK
MANDATES ARE PREVENTING THEIR
TEACHERS FROM DOING THAT SAME
THING?
>> OUR TEACHERS ARE INTERESTING
ASKED TO TEACH IN SMALL
CLASSROOM SIZES, TEACHING
OVERSIZED CLASSROOMS WITH
LIMITED RESOURCE.
NOT EVERY CLASSROOM HAS THE
ABILITY TO HAVE WELL-VENT LATED
CLASSROOMS AND THE ABILITY TO
MAKE SURE EVERY CHILD IS
PROTECTED.
MANDATES MAKE SENSE WHEN YOU ASK
A TEACHER TO PROTECT THE WHOLE
CLASSROOM.
I LIVE WITH MY PARENTS
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED AND MY NIECE
15 WHO WEARS A MASK.
MY RESPONSIBILITY WAS TO EXPLAIN
TO THOSE KIDS WHY I WAS DOING
SOMETHING THEY WEREN'T DOCK AND
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE TO PUT THAT
MASK BACK ON.
I TOOK IT OFF BECAUSE I WAS
SPEAKING REMOTELY AND WANTED ALL
OF THEM TO HEAR ME.
THE HARMER POINT I WANT EVERYONE
TO TAKE FROM THIS, THIS IS
COMPLICATED.
WE CANNOT MAKE THIS ABOUT
POLITICS OR SCORING POLITICAL
POINTS.
THIS HAS TO BE ABOUT HOW DO WE
PROTECT OUR FAMILIES?
HOW DO WE NAVIGATE WHAT IS GOING
TO BE A PART OF OUR COMMUNITY
FOR QUITE SOME TIME?
AND AS WE SHIFT FROM PANDEMIC TO
ENDEMIC, WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS IN A
CIVIL AND THOUGHTFUL MANNER AND
NOT USE IT AS A LOLLY TO SCORE
POINTS.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ANOTHER
QUESTION THAT IS OF MAJOR
IMPORTANT CAUSE FOR YOU AND
PASSION.
THE SUPREME COURT'S CONSERVATIVE
MAJORITY JUST UPHELD ALABAMA'S
NEW CONGRESSIONAL MAP THAT MAP A
LOWER COURT FOUND DIMINISHED THE
LOWER POWER OF THE STATE'S BLACK
VOTERS.
THE SUPREME COURT SAYS IT WILL
HEAR ARGUMENTS OVER THE MASK,
THAT PUTS A KEY VOTING PRIVILEGE
ON THE TABLE.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU BY THAT?
>> I'M VERY CONCERNED.
I THINK IT'S WORTH NOTING CHIEF
JUSTICE ROBERTS, THE ARCHITECT
OF GETTING THE VOTING ACT SIDED
WITH THE MINORITY SAYING THIS
IS, INDEED, A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF
THE EROSION OF VOTING RIGHTS AND
WHEN JOHN ROBERTS SAYS YOU ARE
DOING SOMETHING WRONG ON VOTING
RIGHTS, WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION.
SADLY, WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
ALABAMA IS HAPPENING ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
WE ARE SEEING AN ATTACK ON
VOTING RIGHTS AND REPUBLICANS
BELIEVING THEY HAVE A MAJORITY
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO CRUSH